what can i say kind of called this one
didn't i uh we predicted this bloodbath
okay it's why i'm wearing red i mean
honestly a few hours ago this shirt was
pure white but it's been bad in the
markets if you're a big clout holder if
you're clowder stephen clowder um you're
not having a good time okay it was
kryptos fire fest look they promised
influencers they promised the world and
they delivered on pretty much nothing
today it's almost like a post-mortem
listen they're still holding on they're
still holding on by a thread but the
writing's on the wall ladies and
gentlemen and we're going to talk about
it right now let's get into it ladies
and gentlemen welcome to the 10 million
dollar studio i'm your host coffee zilla
the internet detective and today we're
talking of course about big clout guys
it was worth 177
when i covered it in march remember that
was around when they launched the
current price of bitcloud
is 73
giving you an roi if you invested of
negative 59 percent which i think is
just
swell some of the best you see these
days uh ladies and gentlemen just
remember and this is really important
let's bring down the board here um this
is a coin here that was backed or should
i say platform they call themselves a
social platform decentralized social
media they were backed by some of the
biggest brains in the world the guys who
are on top figuring out what the next
trend is you got people like a16z
chamath the winky twins they all
collectively decided that it was a good
idea to trust the guy
their leader who goes by the name of
diamond hands well turns out it actually
wasn't now there are about a million
metrics you could measure the um failure
of big clout by not the least of which
is the price but i think the worst
metric for them is clout
ironically enough ladies and gentlemen
this is a um
graph of their search terms and as you
can see they've just slowly sort of been
sliding into obscurity both on google
and more broadly people just aren't
interested in it people really just
aren't talking about it the way they
used to and i think part of that is
we'll start with the failure why it
failed i think part of it's due to the
rocky launch where they just stole a lot
of people's identities i don't know if
you guys remember that they took the top
like several thousand uh public profiles
took their twitter profiles and just
threw them on the site and let people
invest in them before people even knew
they were
being used on big cloud which led to
some pretty ironic results like right
now even now the top creators of all
time on big clout are people who have
not joined bitcloud that's right ladies
and gentlemen the number one invested
profiles are elon musk and naval who
both thinks that little clock icon have
not joined they have not okayed their
likeness and their public persona to be
used by big cloud to make money but here
they are the number one and number two
it's completely absurd and i think that
their vision of like this decentralized
um
social media which i actually think is
kind of a good idea i think it really
got overshadowed by this hustle for
money because look i've spent a lot of
time on big clout just looking at what
people are saying i don't have any big
clout but i i just like watch just i'm
interested what are people talking about
and honestly
it's twitter but worse i mean on twitter
yes everybody's self-promoting but on
big cloud everyone's self-promoting so
you'll invest in them so you'll invest
in their creator coin that's why
anyone's on big cloud or why most of
them are on big cloud they're so they
can get rich on bitcloud so everything's
like about like
self-promotion times 10 to the max and
it's just kind of
cringy it's like just everyone's
constantly pitching to you and no one
thought of like the normal users
experience you know like non-famous
people you have to get them on board why
are they gonna join when everyone's
constantly like chilling to get your
money i don't know it was this really
weird thing when i realized that that's
what this had sort of become kind of had
bad incentives from the start a bad
launch but ladies and gentlemen since
this is a postmortem i also think
there's something else we all need to
look at here um and that is what big
clout did with all this money they've
made remember from my last video we
talked about a wallet that big clout got
that got basically 200 million dollars
in bitcoin from people who were trying
to invest in their silly new idea and
they successfully raised all this money
but i think the question is what are
they doing with that money
well according to decrypt this is from
several months ago
diamond hands did an interview with them
they're talking about at the time it was
only 170 million dollars and stash i
know
kind of a joke right but anyway diamond
hands assured decrypt that neither he
nor big clouds developers would use it
to pay themselves saying their financial
incentives are instead tied to the
success of the big clout token so
basically they have now it's like 200
million dollars uh all this money
sitting in a bank a bitcoin wallet and
they said guys trust us we're not hey
hey
trust us don't worry we're not going to
do anything with it and that's of course
when they were telling you guys they
were decentralized they're a
decentralized organization where they
control the keys to where all the money
is right that's how this works but i
think we have to watch these guys
because i think they're gonna do
something with that money they're sure
not gonna let it sit there forever and
um just recently they started moving a
bunch of bitcoin out of it they have
before but i think this is the largest
amount they've moved out since they
moved out 599
bitcoin out of this wallet with all this
money by the way 599 bitcoin is about 28
million dollars ladies and gentlemen um
so yeah exactly chump change for these
guys
so i tried to trace down where someone
was going here we go i put put together
a little map here this is the wallet so
where all this money was they as you can
see they sent
598 bitcoin here to this wallet over
here um and then that wallet was then
sent that same money over here we double
click on that and then as you can see
this wallet now sends uh bitcoin to a
number of different addresses 221
bitcoin here 360 bitcoin here but anyway
the point is we have no idea where this
money's going or ultimately what it's
being used for that's the great thing
about having a founder who's anonymous
right is uh you don't know what they're
gonna do with the money that they've
raised and you can rely on their
promises
all day that supposedly they're not
gonna take a paycheck but we have no
idea what they're gonna do with this
money diamond hands apparently said that
they had uh plans to do use the bitcoin
stash for good but he declined to say if
such good would come from donating the
money to a save the whales style charity
work oh boy or from starting a
foundation to promote the big clout
token which other projects have done in
the past guys we don't know what he's
going to use it for that's the point and
the other point is that 28 million
dollars just got moved from that wallet
and i'm sure a lot more will get moved
soon as well because frankly ladies and
gentlemen big clouds days may be
numbered here they started really high
as we said huge launch because everyone
thought these huge influencers were on
there turns out they weren't really and
the ones that were just wanted to make a
a quick buck off their followers and
then it just kind of stagnated and then
now the coin is crashing so uh with that
happening it'll be interesting to follow
that wallet and see where that money's
going um but ladies and gentlemen that's
basically all i wanted to cover for this
is let you guys know what was going on i
gotta say kind of call this one hope you
guys didn't lose money thank you so much
for watching save your clout and i will
see you guys in the next one